you which is that ben wallace who's a
defense secretary um has just tweeted
that after careful consideration and
discussing with colleagues and family i
have taken the decision not to enter the
contest for leadership on the
conservative party i am very grateful to
all my parliamentary colleagues and
wider members who have pledged support
it has not been an easy choice to make
but my focus is on my current job in
keeping this great country safe i wish
the very best of luck to all candidates
and hope we swiftly return to focusing
on the issues that we are all elected to
address so that is the latest there
coming in from ben wallis there saying
that actually he will not be putting his
hat into the ring to stand as the next
leader of the conservative party and
indeed as the next prime minister of the
uk let me just come back to you there
richard what's your reaction then to
this latest news then from ben wallace
i think you have to respect that
decision i mean i think
it's not an easy job to do it's a job
that's got to be all-consuming um and
and you have to respect the fact that
if he's putting his family first one of
the reasons i have never stood for
parliament is to put my family first
well it's um he had been tipped as one
of the favorites actually hadn't he to
actually put his name into the into the
ring and also to lead as um as as to
take over as the leader of the party and
indeed to take over from boris johnson
as the prime minister so removing him
from the mix then that certainly changes
things doesn't it
yes it does in terms of that was
probably a good prospect that he would
have been able to make the final two but
leadership contests in the conservative
party can be very fast moving in any
party can be very fast moving and things
can change quite rapidly um i think you
have to have a look at who's standing
what they're standing for and what their
past records are
i
i as i say i find i find rishi very
compelling in terms of his his intellect
his ability to get on top of the detail
which again is something i think that
the boris missed and i do think there is
a question mark that you you have to
consider about some of those who
remained in government um in the last 48
hours i think when once the revelations
came out once the letter from lord
macdonald came out i i i find it a
little concerning i think people need to
explain why they did that